started my 90-day challenge I came here
to visit with my dry cleaner here in
North Vancouver so I'm going to try
those visits again and see if we can
have conversation
swing this around a bit
see
got mountains in the distance there and
that's the top of grouse
there is a basically a gondola that goes
up to the top there's also a hat that I
have walked called the grouse grind it
takes anywhere from 30 minutes to an
hour and a half
see how
you cheap internet garage on shiitakes
put a captain table so visually the new
could she be the autoresponder patio no
corona' chicken money cuckoo cuckoo
housing what
Coco I need OPC da da da and I got money
Sumida when I'm young my god donated
donated stone head growing on Mulan
queue boom you Johnny
yang as often Princessa me when I die
the 20-mile g10 oh no now
yeah butoh they're 90 days I'm almost
done
and I showed you various you know of my
activities in language tourney one of
main ones is getting on my supper and I
now have the new version new I think
I've got it on my iPad or can't see it
and one of the things that's really good
about it is that I can look at the text
sentence by sentence because it's
difficult on the stepper to look at a
whole text these podcasts are 60 minutes
long right just swipe it with my finger
and the next sentence shows up and then
I read the next sentence and if there's
anything that I don't understand I look
it up I couldn't even hear the
text-to-speech and that's that and then
I can go on to the next sentence and so
I can here we are next sentence and I
can read it and so you know all the
while in these 90 days a number of
things have happened it I got a
transcriber to shorten the text makes it
easier on the eye link I started using
the new I like I think I pet I'm
learning so I can't say that I've become
fluent but I progressed in terms of my
learning technology in terms of my
availability of Korea resources turns in
my confidence so I feel very happy that
the ninety days are over and that I did
it and all the best to you in your
Lantern